Peggy's 16 join us as we make ready for
one dangerous trip in the harshest
environment ever inhabited by mankind
Mars with its terraforming aborted
hundreds of years ago in a murderous
sons of boots the Red Planet isn't
exactly a hospitable place and every
nook and cranny of the forsaken planet
holds deadly lurking threats many hybrid
creatures roamed the canyons of Mars
originally bioengineered by the first
settlers from the genetic makeup of
animals found on earth
they have since gotten loose creating a
budding ecosystem the harsh living
conditions led them to mutate along the
centuries developing effective defense
mechanisms most of them are aggressive
and territorial downright deadly should
you fight them and prepare
but the other human survivors can be
just as dangerous
ever since Mars got isolated from Earth
multiple factions have risen the
corporation Aurora and its rival
abundance which you are pass over among
the most powerful more secretive
factions exists such as the underworld
mobs who call themselves the quarry the
merchants guild of Noctis and the less
lucky mutants whose DNA generated after
being exposed to solar radiations and
who are now living as slaves and
outcasts you will be able to befriend
those factions or antagonize them
depending on your actions and your
choices throughout the story
hopefully you have all the tools to
survive the harsh environment of Mars
Technomancer powers can cover a wide
range of uses you have access to
damaging powers such as the most basic
electric art or the more advanced than
its external but also support powers the
electric fist will help you control the
pace of combat thanks to its superior
stunning and disrupting ability Electric
weapon will imbue your current blade
mace or staff with deadly sparks and
magnetic shield will surround you with
an intangible field negating incoming
damage for a time you all Technomancer
powers are devastating in their own
right but you'll have to use them
tactically as each use will cost you
focus slow the generating resources each
of your powers are upgraded by spending
points in the skill tree but they also
have access to two mutually exclusive
upgrades changing the way
paves your Technomancer powers
complements your combat stance of choice
combat with the Stars signature
particular man sir with a blade and gun
mark of the role or Mason shield the
weapons favored by soldiers the combat
with the staff is based on mobility and
area damage using sweet moves and blows
its wide attack and stagger multiple
enemies at a time and so this stance is
most effective against big groups of
enemy fighting with the blade and gun
requires agility in purple dodging the
blade has a higher critical rate than
other weapons and can poison enemies for
additional damage at fight the nail gun
lets you control the pace of the combat
by interrupting enemies from farm land
finishing blows at Southridge finally
the mason shield combat stance focuses
on defense
it is less mobile than other stances but
allows you to block incoming attacks and
gun shots carrying at the last second
lets you stagger enemies a bit like a
deadly counter-attack just like fatigued
nomads see each of these three stances
has its own skill tree where you can
gain new skills but also improve them
using different upgrade paths whatever
your stance of choice may be your
companions will help you in combat they
all have their own talents complementing
your own tanks ranged combat specialist
healer in the midst of battle you'll be
able to assign them different behaviors
to adapt depending on the current
situation and what you want to do such
as focusing on melee combat or keeping
you alive upgrading your arsenal will be
equally important you will loot and buy
better weapons and armor or receive them
as a graceful war each has its own
bonuses and some of them also have
crafting slots allowing you to further
improve their stats according to your
preferences and place on you'll be able
to improve damage resistance as well as
add various special effects such as
disruption resistance to specific damage
types energy regeneration and more
however brute force won't be the only
tool at your disposal to overcome
adversity if you decide to select them
different talents will help you take
eternity groups the stealth talent will
help you sneak around and taking down
targets silently to weaken a group of
enemies or simply to pass through
unnoticed traps and lock-picking allows
you to set traps on the patrol route of
enemies but also often lets you access
alternative routes by unlocking doors
the science and charisma talents will
allow you to try and diffuse tense
situations before they explodes
successfully averting a crisis without
having to fight I'm gonna get the hell
out of all fear and don't look back I
don't sure yeah sure pilot
survive the many dangers of Mars and you
will become the most powerful
Technomancer master forge the destiny of
Mars June 28 on ps4 Xbox one PC